just one day after a suspicious package
was found at George Soros's Westchester
home another suspicious package was
intercepted on its way to the clintons
Westchester home another suspicious
package sent to Barack Obama Eric Holder
John Brennan at CNN for some reason even
though he doesn't work there lots of
suspicious packages we will analyze what
it means who it's likely from is it a
lunatic or is it a dirty trick this is
very close to the midterm elections the
timing is curious then Democrats have
finally settled on a pre midterm
election message this one is really
innovative really creative you're not
going to want to miss it
then heidi heitkamp in north dakota
can't catch a break president Coffey
mercilessly trolls former community
organizer Barack Obama and a full
quarter of American college students
have PTSD symptoms following the 2016
election drink up those tears
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
NOLA
[Music]
if only I had my leftist ears tumblr I'm
on the road the cough FA on campus tour
chugs along it rolls along here I'll be
a Grand Canyon University tonight will
be I'll be speaking here at 7:00 p.m.
Eastern or 7:00 p.m. Pacific rather
10:00 p.m. Eastern should be a lot of
fun can't wait to talk to the kids then
we're heading on down to South Dakota
then we're going to Alabama we got a lot
going on this week and I'm glad that
we're able to do the show on the road
because people are now sending bombs in
the mail this is not very good we don't
know anything about who sent them but we
will try to analyze first let's make a
little money honey speaking of these
sorts of things let's talk about battle
box oh I've told you about battle box a
fabulous advertiser a wonderful thing
especially for men you know so many of
these subscription boxes you subscribe
and I don't know they give you like
hotel room soaps or something it's a
little dainty not exactly for men this
is great you know that a lot of those
boxes from other companies are full of
junk and they're full of samples or
whatever battle box as a monthly
subscription for men who understand that
it is their mission and responsibility
to be prepared for any situation these
things are so cool I think I told you
when we got it had all these knives and
camping equipment and all this sort of
thing I'm like chasing drew around the
office with a machete it's a lot of fun
it's your monthly subscription for
hand-picked outdoor survival and
everyday carry gear you can try it right
now at try battle box com slash Knoll
scan or wles that is tr Y be a TTL Bo
XCOM slash nulls don't you put an e in
try battle box com you will not get
where you want to go they start at just
25 bucks per month it is a great value
and there is really really cool stuff in
there right now our listeners get a free
tactical knife when you sign up for your
first battle box at tribe battle box
comm slash Knoll Skinner wles
I have the knife it is super cool man I
really like this thing get it it's free
don't be stupid
try battle box dark on flash Knolls
right now you get your first battle box
plus a free tactical knife that try
battle box be a TTL comm slash normal
scanner wles moving from knives onto
bombs we have to talk about these
many suspicious packages sent around it
was discovered that they did have
explosive material in them pretty
rudimentary not very sophisticated
nevertheless I think the one that was
sent to George Soros's house was
detonated nobody was hurt nobody's been
hurt which is why I'm allowed to joke
about this and I'm very pleased that I
can if someone had been hurt it would be
such a downer one it would be a very bad
thing we don't want to have acts of
domestic terrorism in our country well
beyond the acts of domestic terror
perpetrated by an Tifa and the left you
know
elected Democrats telling people to go
to Republicans homes harass them where
their children sleep that kind of thing
we don't want anymore
acts of civil unrest or political
violence in America the timing here is
really really weird where what are we 13
days away from the midterm elections for
the last two weeks and news cycles have
had the headlines Democrats mob violence
now all of a sudden all of these attacks
come out I'm not take off your tinfoil
hats I'm not saying that this is some
grand conspiracy I'm not saying George
Soros sent bombs to himself or anything
like that I'm just saying but timing is
pretty weird
there are a lot of weird political dirty
tricks on both sides of the aisle that
happened that happened as we approach
elections and so I want to know who this
is who this guy is who sent it what the
motivations were I don't think we should
jump to any conclusions whatsoever this
is what happens we did a whole episode
the other day on how when people in
politics get angry people in politics go
mad and when people in politics go mad
they get stupid don't get stupid don't
get passionate stay cool stay removed I
got to tell you President Trump in the
White House and vice president Pence or
handling this perfectly I'll show you
this clip then we can compare it to how
the Democrats have reacted to other acts
of political violence in the United
States take it away President Trump the
full weight of our government is being
deployed to conduct this investigation
and bring those responsible for these
despicable acts to justice we will spare
no resources or expense in this effort
and I just want to tell you
in these times we have to unify we have
to come together and send one very clear
strong unmistakable message that acts or
threats of political violence of any
kind have no place in the United States
of America exactly right this is exactly
the right response compare that to what
we've heard over the last two weeks from
Maxine Waters Maxine Waters a little
earlier than that Hillary Clinton Eric
Holder who says when Republicans go low
kicked them Hillary Clinton who says you
can't be civil
who called half the country deplorable
and irredeemable Maxine Waters who
explicitly said go out there harass
conservatives where they are in the
street where they sleep additionally
where they sleep you had Cory Booker
saying get up in the faces of
congressmen this was the right response
from President Trump and it stands in
stark contrast to how Democrats have
been reacting to political violence that
we know is motivated as political and
partisan motivations so what do we make
of this this is pretty weird I actually
lived I grew up right down the road from
where George Soros lives and where the
Clintons are I didn't know at the time
that Hillary was my fourth cousin twice
removed so I never had to sit through
any Thanksgiving dinners with her
niryabi lady - so what what can we make
of this we before we try to analyze the
motivations let's try to analyze what
the effect of this is what this looks
like from the outside perspective let's
assume that the person sending the bombs
is rational which is a bizarre you know
that's a tough assumption to make you
could just be a total lunatic very
likely is but let's say the person is
rational what is the effect of sending
the bombs you've got a midterm elections
that were supposed to be a blue wave
where the polls have turned all in the
direction of Republicans and
conservatives in recent weeks you've got
headlines for the last two weeks all
about Democrat political violence you're
now 13 days away in what way if this
were sent by a conservative in what way
would this help conservatives all
would do is turn the momentum it
possibly turned the momentum back
against conservatives and Republicans in
favor of the left all it would do is
undercut what we've seen for weeks and
weeks and even longer than that if you
go back to the election of Donald Trump
of political violence from the left so
as a matter of politics this sort of
stunt would only benefit Democrats and
left wingers and would only harm
conservatives and Republicans if this
person is rationally motivated why now
why would they send these rudimentary
bombs now wouldn't they send them I
don't know after Hillary Clinton I don't
know after Maxine what this is a better
example Maxine Waters actually called
for political violence that Hillary
Clinton and Eric Holder they can kind of
walk a line and say oh no we didn't
quite do it wouldn't they have sent if
they were motivated because of the calls
for violence from the left wouldn't they
have sent them weeks ago months ago it
seems like they would have if they were
motivated to advance a political agenda
wouldn't they have sent them when there
was a an actual political agenda on the
line when there actually were the
confirmation of Judge Kavanaugh for
instance when it looked like Kavanaugh
was going to get railroaded in his
confirmation process wouldn't they send
it when it looked like conservatives
were losing when it looked like there
was something really to gain from it so
I they don't gain anything in that
regard so Lent then let's examine the
other one which is that it's not a dirty
trick it's not some rational actor it's
a lunatic which seems to make a fair
amount of sense we know that one of
these packages was sent to John Brennan
former CIA director former communist
voter he voted for Gus Hall in the 1970s
a awful leftist who has been pitiless
and absurd and hysterical in his
condemnation of President Trump and the
Republicans he was a political hack he
should never have gotten the job under
Barack Obama in the first place now he's
made himself into a Twitter celebrity
attacking the president okay they sent
the package to him care of CNN but John
Brennan works at MSNBC he's an MSNBC
contributor
so I don't understand Ark in favor of
the person is a total lunatic the return
address with Debbie wasserman-schultz so
they're trying to make clear all of
these packages going out within a couple
days of each other
the return address the person who is
sending this is clearly trying to make
it apparent to everybody that this is
aimed at Democrats debbie Wasserman
Schultz was the former head of the
Democrat National Committee now
interestingly Debbie wasserman-schultz
was also the head of the DNC when the
primary election was unfair to Bernie
Sanders and was favorable to Hillary
Clinton okay a lot of these are Obama
holdovers obviously the Clintons debbie
Wasserman Schultz okay
I don't see a political motive for a
right-winger so I predict if it if it is
a right-winger it is a true Looney tune
I mean you you will see tinfoil hats and
wacky behavior even wackier and less
less explainable than engaging in
political violence could it be a dirty
trick yeah anything's possible
anything's possible I'm not saying it is
I'm not saying that's likely that it is
what I'm saying is reserve your judgment
until we find out who this person is
that there is clearly a political
motivation if this person is rational
there is clearly convenient timing here
if this person is rational reserve your
judgment until we find out what happens
president Trump said it very well he
said we have got to bring this person to
justice we got to find out who it is
bring them to justice there's no place
for this in American politics that's
true regardless of their political
motivations that's true regardless of
their ideological affiliation just wait
and see I we one should always urge
caution and these kinds of things
because especially right before
elections they are they are often
designed to elicit an emotional response
don't give it to them don't fall into
that trap okay regardless of who sent
the bombs and what the bombs mean and
what the bombs really are President
Trump yesterday he extolled the virtues
of nationalism over globalism and this
is elicited a obviously a violent
response from the left but it is
elicited a violent rhetoric as well
now he said I am a nationalist I think
this was the first time he's talked
about nationalism a lot but he said it's
so explicitly he made a point that this
is the thesis I am a nationalist and
what does that mean you know we had your
impose on you as that great book out the
virtue of nationalism and nationalism is
pitted against globalism nationalism
saying that the world order the
Westphalian system the nation-states
that we have are the best system to
preserve liberty freedom and prosperity
maybe it's not this the most peaceful
sometimes nations go to war with each
other
but it preserves Liberty as opposed to
globalism in which people and their
communities and their states in their
countries cede their sovereignty and
their freedom to super national
institutions that don't have any
particular allegiance to them or their
families or their communities this is
like the European Union we could say or
the International Criminal Court that's
the difference and Trump says between
those two things we're not ceding our
freedom we're not ceding our Liberty I
am defending the American Founding and
what has led us to so much peace and
prosperity and liberty and enjoyment for
hundreds of years I'm defending the
nation how do you think the Democrats
responded how do you think Democrats and
CNN respond to this here is Democrat
congressman Gregory Meeks interpreting
the real meaning of this statement in
just one second before we get to that
I've got to make a little more money
honey how's that for a cliffhanger
mm-hmm we got to think candid kind what
your think you're looking at me you're
saying Michael you don't have many
virtues you're not a great adonis of a
man fair enough I grant that but look at
these teeth look at these two you look
at he's shot he's pearly white teeth I
have got to thank candid Co you do not
need to go through the hassle or
long-term treatment of wire braces when
I was a kid I looked you know awful
because I had these metal braces on and
they're very awkward you don't have to
go through that there are now new
services like candid Co straighter and
brighter teeth in an average of six
months and they cost 65% less than
braces it makes it so easy and it makes
clear aligners they're sent directly to
your home and are customized
specifically for you to
straighten your teeth they fix crooked
teeth crowding protrusion and gaps the
first step is to purchase the model and
kit will be sent to your home you can
take impressions of your teeth after you
send it back
candidates network of orthodontists
review your specific case and provides
you with a 3d preview of what your
treatment will look like
you'll get your plan you got a real
orthodontist it's the main reason that
you got to love candid is you're not
dealing with some faceless service
you're dealing with an actual
orthodontist you know you're gonna get
tip-top care you are one step away from
getting straighter and whiter teeth take
advantage of candidates risk-free model
and keep guarantee plus use my dedicated
link do it right now do it and get these
pearly white teeth doesn't matter if
you're not an Adonis of a human being
you can still have pearly white teeth
and that will impress people pearly
I got pearly whites too but you can
straighten them go to candid koat.com /
go FFA co v fe fe to get 25% off of your
modeling kit candid code comm / go FFA
co v fe fe cuz it doesn't matter if
they're pearly wife if they're all
jagged and awful you're not gonna be
doing very well when you try to meet the
honey of your life go there right now
candid code comm / co if fe co v f EF n
straighten out those teeth come on man
first impressions are everything okay so
how did the democrats and CNN respond
that you know in they're typically
stayed normal way this is how they
responded to Donald Trump saying a very
basic thing something that all of our
founders and framers would say something
that all normal people in the history of
the United States would say I support
the American nation I don't want to give
our freedom away to extra super national
organizations here's the reaction my
balance is a person that wants to hope
to do well frankly not caring about our
country so much and you know what we
can't have that you know have a word it
sort of became old-fashioned it's called
a nationalist and I say really we're not
supposed to use that word you know what
I am I'm an
okay alright so what's your reaction to
that congressman my first reactant that
to that is they said of them to a
nationalist is as children and that
apparently is what this president is and
to say that we are better than or you
know it reminds me of the kinds of words
that came from people like Hitler who
thought that in Germany he was a
nationalism so just to begin that isn't
true
I thought President Trump said it very
well in that speech what Gregory Meeks
said is not true nationalism and
chauvinism are not synonyms so we've
heard of chauvinism you hear of male
chauvinism or this show it's kind of
boastful prideful being braggart about
your country or your community when it
comes it comes from this probably
apocryphal French soldier nicholas java
and he's an apocryphal probably
apocryphal french soldier in Napoleon's
army that isn't nationalism nationalism
says we protect the country we defend
the interests of a country we extol the
virtues of free nation states that we
can interact with if we're talking about
Chauvin we're actually talking about the
opposite of nationalism you're talking
about imperialism you're talking about
globalism you're talking about armies
that try to go out through the rest of
the world take over other places conquer
other places that isn't nationalism and
people bandy these terms about they'd I
guarantee you Gregory Meeks has no idea
where the word chauvinism comes from but
that's what it comes from also show the
reason I say this soldier Siobhan was
probably apocryphal is that we have no
record that he existed and hid tales of
his and the use of the word chauvinism
was used by critics of Napoleon used by
critics of Bonaparte ISM so even that
it's it's a term that was invented in
derision it's a term that was invented
to be used as an attack you know that
the left accuses the right of
anti-intellectualism all the time the
right is so much more intellectual than
the left or skeptical of experts were
skeptical of into
Jules but if you're gonna use a word I
do find the people on the right you know
what it means of course they do they use
language appropriately they use language
to mean what it means on the left they
use these slogans all the time that's
why they have political correctness is
to use terms that don't have real
meanings or that have perverse meanings
or that have meanings that orange what
they purport to be I always I want to
take the opportunity to point this out
whenever I can the right is far more
intellectual than the left how many
public policy think tanks are there on
the left the left has the university is
finally able to they have taken over the
educational system but how many think
tanks dedicated to public policy do they
have like to maybe Brookings is kind of
left I don't know two or three how many
are on the right about a zillion you've
got heritage you've got a EEI
you've got Cato you've got the Hudson
you've got all of these institutions of
public policy because the right actually
is better about this we just don't go
boasting about it all the time we're not
chauvinists about it all the time to use
their word this reminds me I was talking
to John Fugelsang
the actor and comedian at Politico and
talked about him a little bit yesterday
but he we were arguing about the Bible
on Twitter and he thought he got a slam
dunk he said you haven't read this
passage of numbers to prove that
abortion is great and God approves of
abortion they sent me the passage I
looked at it and I realized one of the
words was mistranslated the word for
miscarry the word that he thought meant
abortion was just mistranslated so I
just googled all different translations
of it every other translation was
different it didn't use that where was
just one poor translation he this is the
left there so intellectually pompous but
they don't have a lot backing them up
they don't have a lot of support and I
think this is why the the right is so
much better at trolling them you know
comedy requires wit it you have to have
a quick wit to do it and a president
Trump totally trolled Barack Obama the
other day it's because the right is is
harder better faster stronger you know
to quote Kanye this probably why Kanye
likes us that's why he's got all that
dragon energy flowing through them
they're just a little bit quicker and
president Trump use this dragon energy
pretty hard on the immigration
an issue he tweeted out of video of
Barack Obama with the caption that said
I agree with President Obama 100% here's
the video of Obama we are a generous and
welcoming people here in the United
States but those who enter the country
illegally and those who employ them
disrespect the rule of law and they are
showing disregard for those who are
following the law we simply cannot allow
people to pour into the United States
undetected undocumented unchecked and
circumventing the line of people who are
waiting patiently diligently and
lawfully to become immigrants in this
country who is that man could somebody
tell me who that man is and why he's
wearing Barack Obama's face as a mask
why he really does a good impression of
his voice - how could you man that was
Barack Obama I think from 2005 back
before Democrats had completely given
way to the extreme fringes of their
party by whom they are now held hostage
so you had obviously illegal immigration
is illegal it's not that complicated
Democrats realized that they had to veer
hard to the left they got angry they got
mad they got stupid now they're held
hostage by this lawless base and it's
true of course I agree with Barack Obama
there - Barack Obama agrees with Donald
Trump there I was waiting for Barack
Obama to go on and say that's why we
need to renegotiate NAFTA that's why we
got to pull out of the Paris climate
Accord that's why we have to make
America great again make America great
again folks
got to do it okay we're getting totally
killed over here you know China China's
totally killing us I don't know good I
could go on for hours illegal
immigration is a winning issue and among
the vast majority of Americans including
Democrats the Democrats made a huge
miscalculation when they allowed
themselves to be become dependent on and
hostage to that extreme lawless fringe
of their party this is why President
Trump is running so hard on it illegal
immigration is a violation it is a
violation of our borders is a violation
of our laws in our country and our
sovereignty and our freedom and our
votes it is a total violation it's why
people of both parties react so strongly
to it it's why Trump is right to run so
hard on this and just before the
midterms again we were talking about
dirty tricks when we were talking about
those suspicious bomb packages there is
a gigantic caravan of illegal aliens
crossing up through Latin America that
is a do to arrive on our border I don't
know the morning of Election Day I mean
the timing is almost perfect
what is this care of me what is this
Caravan who's behind it this is
certainly a ploy by the left we know who
helped to organize it it's leftist
institutions and leftist politicians but
it actually sort of plays to both the
extreme fringes of the Democrats who now
run that party and to the right plays
more to the right because we've got more
people who care about it on that side
but we know that this caravan which is
now up to something like 14 or 15
thousand people started out as just a
couple hundred people in Honduras was
was begun by this Honduran ex politician
and radio host he's the host of this
show called Without Borders and the
organization that has been pushing these
caravans for a long time there was way
blow sinfronteras people Without Borders
as this radical leftist Honduran
politician Bartolo twenties so this guy
Bartolo Fuentes is involved in this he's
trying to push people up and push
illegal aliens into the country then a
news report in Latin America said that
Bartolo Fuentes was going to pay for all
of the provisions to get up to the
United States gonna pay for everything
so you know to hire one of these Coyotes
to hire one of these awful human
traffickers to get people into the
country that can cost $7,000 $10,000
these people don't have that kind of
money so youyou see a lot of both
ambitious and desperate people joining
into the caravan to try to make it in
without having to shell out ten grand
and do whatever unspeakable acts they
would have to do if they couldn't come
up with that money so now you've got
fourteen thousand people descending on
the border the president has to turn
them away and there's an there's an easy
way to do this at every single debate
from now until Election Day every single
campaign event at every meeting at every
opportunity Republicans should ask
Democrats if they believe
that all of those 14,000 people should
just enter the country should just be
allowed to come in should we open our
doors and let them in because it push it
but it's a wedge issue the Democrats are
gonna there's a wedge between the
radical fringe that holds their party
hostage and the demographics that they
require to vote for them to get elected
there is a major wedge here they should
hit it every single time because there
are a lot of people in this Caravan that
we don't want to get here there was a
there was a report that terrorists
Islamic terrorists are now using the
caravan as an opportunity to come in and
try to infiltrate the country do we know
who these people are do we have hard
proof of this of course not that's the
problem that's the problem with illegal
immigration if we had proof of who these
people work they would be arrested or
worse but we don't because lawlessness
breeds chaos and it breeds a lot of bad
outcomes by the way the people who are
in this Caravan the people who are
around this Caravan are already
admitting that there are criminals here
here here is one of them saying just
that everywhere okay it's criminals in
here I mean it is but it's not that many
I mean peace is good people here trying
to get through through Mexico and then
get to the United States but that
doesn't mean that everybody is a
criminal right well technically
everybody is a criminal because they're
trying to violate one of the most basic
laws of the country which is you can't
enter the country illegally
you can't enter and stay there and live
there illegally and access services and
possibly vote you can't do those things
that is a crime I mean that is a major
crime if a person's first act when they
get to the country they're dreaming of
the country they want a better life i I
don't even mean to mock them I get it if
I lived in Honduras I'd want to come to
the u.s. too but if their first act as
Americans is to violate an essential
American law what kind of citizens are
they going to be do we we don't want
those kind of people you know President
Trump launched his presidential campaign
he said that Latin America is sending
criminals and rapists and murderers and
bad people
that guy's admitting it I mean that guy
there who's in the caravan is admitting
yes some of these people are criminals
there are a lot of criminals absolutely
that's the problem that's why we have to
vet people that's why when when there
are countries that can't adequately vet
those who are coming to the United
States we can't let them in you need
order Americans lives are on the line
and it is the purpose of the American
nation it is the basic and primary
responsibility to protect American
people so the the caravan is chugging
along President Trump should pull out
all of the stops this is only a winner
for him there is no downside there is no
downside to this you should use it as an
opportunity to build the wall he should
take all of that foreign a that used to
go to Honduras or Guatemala or to Mexico
he should tax those remittances hard he
should or cut them off completely
intercept them completely use every
single penny to build that wall it would
be a huge political winner and clearly
it's an important problem you know
people used to say oh walls don't work
that's obviously absurd the Pope said
something to that effect
the Pope guarded by a very important
wall that was built by many other popes
for precisely the reason that walls work
oh we know that walls work very well in
countries that are surrounded by people
trying to constantly get in like Israel
walls do work but people used to say Oh
illegal immigration isn't a big problem
they are it isn't happening that much it
isn't affecting the economy we know it's
happening now we're seeing 14,000 people
descend on the country build the wall
it's it's both necessary as a matter of
practical domestic policy it's also
necessary into foreign policy I suppose
it's also politically totally
advantageous no reason not to do it the
other Trump troll that came out on
Twitter was so good he's in the same
breath he's so good at this is he
tweeted out quote Republicans will
totally protect people with pre-existing
conditions Democrats will not vote
Republican love him love that tweet why
did you send that out because the one
issue that Democrats have thought maybe
they can try to run on other than I hate
Trump and Trump is Hitler is that health
care is going to be taken away if the
Republicans hold the Congress and
the Senate okay I don't think that's
gonna work I don't think that's a big
campaign issue but he should run on that
heart now some people have pointed out
they've said well you know he's missing
the premise if we're talking about
pre-existing conditions then we're not
talking about insurance insurances to
protect against risks not against things
that we already know that we have so it
has to be a separate program which is
probably just part of the welfare system
and yeah yes you're right you're totally
right I totally agree with you the tweet
that President Trump sent out is not
precise it buys into a definition of
insurance that we all have to go along
with but which is not correct and not
precise you're totally right I don't
care I don't care I do not care
politics is a practical science
sometimes you have to use the
circumstances that are at your disposal
and you have to take into consideration
a lot of other factors like timing like
the rhetoric that your opponent is using
and like the issues the core issues that
people care about people don't want to
lose their health insurance they don't
want the government to take over their
health insurance either you've got to
focus on that you're totally right I
hope that we can over time change the
culture change our vocabulary so that
people don't so the people first of all
understand what insurance is because
this isn't just about pre-existing
conditions everybody misuses the word
insurance insurance is to protect
against risk and dangers insurance is
not to pay for things that we know we're
going to pay for and yet when you go to
your annual physical I don't go to
annual physicals but if I did you would
use your health insurance to process
that payment it's not insurance if you
go every year
it's not you know you're gonna do it but
we misuse that anyway so I think you're
totally right but politics is a
practical science and speaking of
politics as a practical science heidi
heitkamp democrat north dakota cannot
catch a break and the narrative is
breaking so well for conservatives right
now which is why I want to find out the
story on this bomb thing but it's
breaking so well we'll get to all of
that but if you want to see it you've
got to go to Daley wire calm I'm sorry
what do you want me to do we got to make
a little money honey we got to keep the
lights on even in this awful fluorescent
lighting in this hotel that I'm in for
my speech tonight as part of the yeah
they on campus store at Grand Canyon
University go to daily wire.com it's ten
bucks a month $100 for annual membership
you get me you get the intro flavin show
you get the Ben Shapiro show you get to
ask questions in the mailbag you get to
ask questions and conversation you get
another Kingdom you get to see the whole
thing on Monday nonsubscribers have to
wait just for the audio they got to wait
until Friday go subscribe right now you
got a lot of stuff get your questions
and for the mailbag we will be doing
that on Friday this week go to daily
wire.com we'll be right back with a lot
more
so speaking of politics as a practical
science poor Heidi Heitkamp she can't
catch a break she's the one she's the
Democrat senator who published a list of
alleged sexual assault victims published
a full-page ad in a newspaper without
getting the consent of the people who
suffered sexual assault and and some
people who didn't support her and people
who say we weren't sexually assaulted in
the first place
it sent her campaign plunging she'd
already been nine or ten points behind
she dropped to 12 points behind now I
think she's 16 points behind falling
apart but she won't suspend the campaign
and now James O'Keefe decided to kick
her well she's done I guess he took the
Eric Holder advice and just dealt this
brutal blow to her campaign got her
campaign staffers on the record to admit
that she's a liar here they are after
the election just like stuff I don't
like that you know James just does God's
work doesn't he just goes in there and I
don't know how he gets them it's because
you know you get angry you get mad you
get stupid and that's what's happened to
Democrats here so these campaign people
will just admit they'll say oh yeah when
she gets in she's gonna be super liberal
oh yeah she's thought you know right now
I think it's Claire McCaskill Democrat
running in Missouri is running a radio
ad saying I'm not one of those crazy
Democrats direct quote I'm not one of
those crazy Democrats they have to run
against their own party because they
know how unpopular they are
so now they obviously we all know that
heidi heitkamp would be a left-winger if
the democrats had control of the senate
everybody knows that of course you would
one because the parties have gotten much
more ideologically uniform polarized
from one another but uniform within the
parties and because she's a left winger
yeah of course she's a left-wing we all
know that there's just something about
seeing it though there's something about
seeing these staffers come out and say
oh yeah oh let me die was stalking her
the other day oh she's gonna be big
lefty she's going hard after trump if
she gets elected right now she's lying
to the voters obviously that she's lying
to the voters but you know once she gets
elected then then she'll be okay she's
probably not gonna get elected as it
stands right now sixteen points down
hard to recoup that in less than two
weeks but it's just it underscores how
the narrative is so important seeing you
know I watched that that I've watched so
many awful left-wing movies over the
Barack Obama one south side with you the
Clarence Thomas movie where he's a
monster you know and about a Nita hill
who's some Saint I guess I don't know
and the movies are really important
because you see it now these movies lie
they don't tell the truth they
misrepresent the historical record that
JFK movie by Oliver Stone total
historical lies but you see it and the
narrative sticks with you so if they can
use the narrative and the culture to
tell lies why can't we use the narrative
in the culture to tell the truth this is
what happened with the Gosnell movie you
know I was written by Andrew Clavin it
was a star Dean Cain Nick Searcy
directed it's so Rachel did a great job
performing in it and this movie comes
out and it opens pretty big release
nationally six fifty theaters I think
did very well outperformed expectations
and but there the theaters are starting
to drop it slowly
they don't want this movie about an
abort you remember who Kermit Gosnell is
probably you don't because it was never
covered by the media it was and now
they're trying to drop the movie from
theaters Kermit Gosnell is the biggest
serial killer in American history he
killed countless babies unborn babies
then babies that were born he would
deliver babies he would play with them
and then he would kill them hiki no I
don't even want to get into it watch the
movie it is so disgusting and
psychopathic the things that this guy
did he
was revealed because he injured women in
his office so they were finally after a
while there was an investigation but a
lot of people knew about it politicians
covered it up and the media would not
show up to the trial now they're trying
to cover this up so there was this this
girl Cathy Zhu who's a young political
commentator she's on Twitter and all
social media she tweeted this at
yesterday she said yesterday I was
pro-choice I believe that women should
have a say and the government shouldn't
be interfering with our lives today I'm
pro-life today I'm pro-life
after watching Gosnell and doing
in-depth research I finally understand
the horrors of loopholes in late term
abortions please go watch Gosnell that's
the point that's the point of making the
movie the point is not to make money
movies don't make money movies almost
never make money all of Hollywood is a
scam you probably already knew that but
it is but the point is to change the
culture and change the narrative and the
Gosnell movie is clearly succeeding in
that and it's pretty cool that Drew has
a hand in that because he wrote the
script we have got to do more of this
we've got to do more of this and not
just on abortion I mean this obviously
that is such a basic issue that it
motivates a lot of people it's a
question of life and a culture of life
but there are a lot of other issues too
and we should be reclaiming that an era
that's so important to see harsh truths
we use euphemisms even the word abortion
is a euphemism right it's not the
abortion used to refer to miscarriages a
spontaneous abortion that they say
pregnancy would abort that's not really
what we're talking about abortion is
going in and ending a human life ending
a human life that's already begun and
you're going and making a decision to
end it to kill it this is very important
for the millennial generation this is
very important for what we call the
snowflake generation seeing harsh truths
this is why it's so insidious to use
politically correct language is it makes
you so much more fragile even just you
to use the term undocumented dreaming
future American whatever their new
jargon is instead of illegal alien I
don't say illegal alien to be mean to
people I say it so that we can deal in
reality with what the issues are that
we're
talking about their illegal aliens
they're not future undocumented dreaming
whatever whatever's when you use that
soft language those soft euphemisms you
get very frail you get very easily
triggered when someone speaks reality
this is what happened in the 2016
election there's a new study out I
sometimes worry that we make a
caricature out of Millennials and the
snowflakes you know that I don't want to
make a caricature out of them but now we
have a study to back it up out of
Arizona State they interviewed a ton of
students I think it was seven or eight
hundred so I'm at a huge sample size but
significant of all all various genders
and races and socioeconomic backgrounds
they found 25% of college students have
been traumatized by the 2016 election
they're suffering the symptoms of
post-traumatic stress disorder they're
really suffering and that's not that's
not that they're just saying they are
and they aren't they actually are it is
manifesting in clinically high levels of
stress because a Republican won the
White House because that's what a
republic maybe a little boorish
Republican maybe a little uncommon
Republic and uncommon ly successful
Republican too but that's why a
politician that they didn't like won a
political office and they are breaking
down they're having nervous breakdowns
PTSD you got to toughen up kids you've
got to toughen up I mean this is nobody
benefits from this it is not
compassionate to be soft and to treat
adults like they are children that isn't
compassionate at all it hurts them it
hurts their ability to interact in the
world it hurts their mental health their
emotional well-being and certainly it
harms society this is the issue with
transgenderism this is why I think it's
so awful and exploitative and cynical
for the left to try to push their
political agenda on the backs of the
very small number of people who suffer
from gender confusion it's awful it's so
cynical they really shouldn't do it
because one it's leading to a lot more
cultural confusion and it's not helping
the people who suffer from this
condition there's a major genital
reconstructive surgeon professor
Miroslav de George's avec you [ __ ] I
don't
not great at my Eastern European
languages but anyway professor Miroslav
has pointed out that there is sex change
regret on the rise he said quote those
wishing the reversal of the surgery have
spoken about crippling levels of
depression following their transition
and in some cases even contemplated
suicide we know this from the numbers we
really know this from the statistics the
levels of anxiety and depression among
transgender people people suffering from
gender confusion are almost exactly the
same after the surgery as they were
before and then some people that can
change in either direction it isn't
helping people to indulge in delusions
and to mutilate their bodies for them
there's no evidence that it helps
anybody it's it's not helpful to live in
lies lies are not helpful
the truth is helpful the truth can be
harsh it can be painful it can hurt but
the truth will set you free we've got to
start speaking that way too
to American Millennials they're not I
know it seems sweet and nice and oh
they'll grow up and all they'll grow out
of it they won't grow out of it the way
the way you've got to deal with it is
speak harsh language and it's so awkward
because just to use the transgender
issue that's the hottest topic for the
left to talk about 0.4% of the
population they don't love it they'd
love to make an issue out of it if
you're talking to somebody and they use
the wrong pronouns so for instance you
got a guy who thinks he's a girl or very
much wants to be a girl and he says I
want to be referred to as she even
though he is he your friend on the ledge
maybe your friend on the Left calls him
she and then you call him he you are it
is so awkward I've been there I've been
in these conversations it it's so
awkward and you just want to give in
because it seems nice oh the person
suffers from delusions but let's it's so
much easier so much it is easier it is
easier but it isn't more compassionate
it isn't compassionate to live in
delusion and to confuse an entire group
of people you've now paralyzed an entire
generation who's suffering from PTSD for
the most trivial of things I sure hope
we don't have to storm the beaches of
Normandy again because Johnny millennial
is going to be quaking in the kameen
he'll die he'll literally collapse on
the spot if a presidential election is
giving him pts
he will die on the spot he will just
collapse so don't do that don't die on
the spot I'm gonna be talking to a lot
of Millennials and post Millennials
tonight when I'm at Grand Canyon
University for this Yap speech it's
gonna be a lot of fun we've been talking
a lot about simple joys of being right
there are so many more so many more now
and you one of one of the simple joys of
being right is you can get your
questions answered in the mailbag so
make sure you get your questions in by
Friday no show tomorrow but do show
Friday from New York so because I want
to be in New York for about five minutes
and so we'll do it from there it'll be
good I'll get all that dragon energy
from Trump Tower be sure to tune in in
the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Nolt show maybe I'll see you
at 7 p.m. Pacific tonight at Grand
Canyon University if I don't I'll see on
Friday the Michael Nolt show is produced
by seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018